Anch'io vi parlo di passione provo anche
a dare una piccola definizione Secondo
me perché per me la passione è una
dimensione una dimensione molto
particolare Davvero Dove
si trovano il desiderio perché parte dal
desiderio
regolamentata diciamo dalla disciplina e
da grande da grande determinazione però
per farvi capire anche quando è nata io
vi devo raccontare un pochino la mia
storia spero di non tediarvi io nasco
nel 1972 e come volete vedere come
potete vedere ero già questa questa
slide è un pochino più più avanti In
realtà è meno 176/77 ed ero già sulle
macchinine perché io sono nata in una
famiglia dove mio papà faceva il
preparatore di macchina da corsa quindi
ho avuto un esempio incredibile di
passione fortissima e per lui non
contava il tempo la fatica nulla ma
questo l'hanno già l'hanno già spiegato
molto molto bene gli speaker prima di me
Ecco il mio papà quando io sono nata si
trovava in sala
alla prova e riceva una chiamata dalla
mia zia che faceva l'ostetrica lo chiama
e gli dice Impero perché il mio papà si
chiama Impero Impero sei diventato papà
quindi uno si immagina un grandissimo
entusiasmo in realtà lui dice Ah bene è
una bambina si chiama Cristina Ah bene
Latina come sta Latina era la mia mamma
Bene bene Tutto bene Ah ok e mette giù
potete immaginare l'entusiasmo anche la
zia riporta questa entusiasmo alla mamma
che insomma dice Caspita tutta la fatica
che ho fatto una bimba non era
cattiveria era semplicemente il fatto
che lui forse aveva una punta di
delusione che poi in realtà non è così e
me lo dimostra tutti i giorni
lui Sperava di poter trasferire tutto il
suo sapere tutta la sua passione
l'entusiasmo che aveva nel seguire le
macchine da corsa Sperava di poterle
trasferire a un bimbo perché lo riteneva
più più adatto in realtà la trasferito a
me
e quindi sono diventata il suo gasone di
fiducia sono cresciuta in mezzo agli
autodromi in mezzo alle piste
ovviamente di letture da corsa e fate
conto che la mia seggiolina era una
casetta dei ferri una casetta dei ferri
una delle mie giostrine preferite era il
cric perché si caricava e poi
schiacciavo il bottone scendeva di colpo
quindi per me era adrenalina pura e
andavo sempre con lui a provare le
macchine Infatti quando sentite parlare
riesco a riconoscere un Ferrario un
Porsche da lontano riesco anche a capire
se poi mi dite Ma Cristina Ma che cos'è
un 12 cilindri non vi rispondo
sicuramente che non è un servizio di
bicchieri e se mi chiedete Che cos'è un
albero cam sicuramente non vi risponde
che è una pianta grassa perché comunque
per il papà io facevo anche il trasporto
pezzi di ricambio andavo alla rettifica
Insomma faceva un sacco di cose quindi
lui la passione a me la trasferita
tantissimo Quindi cosa faccio cresco
divento grande Cioè arriva il momento di
scegliere la scuola scelgo la scuola e
cosa faccio Secondo voi seguo la
passione meccanica io Volevo fare
meccanica volevo assolutamente essere
come il mio papà una piccola impera
grande così in realtà
poi papà che la sapeva lunga di quel
mondo mi dice Cristina Forse è meglio
che tu scelga qualcosa di un pochino più
adatto diciamo perché comunque si sapeva
il mondo era difficile quel mondo in
modo particolare era difficile quindi
cosa faccio scelgo elettronica
non mi sono discostata di molto faccio
l'elettronica sperimentale ve la faccio
breve Ero l'unica donna con 30 uomini e
in tutta la scuola eravamo 1200 con 5
ragazze come potete immaginare non sono
cresciuta proprio una principessa ho
dovuto imparare a difendermi ma vi
faccio vedere anche qualche foto cresco
arriva il momento di arrivare
all'Università di scegliere l'università
e anche qui volevo seguire la passione
perché mi avevano deviato una volta dico
adesso torno alla carica provo a fare
meccanica qui e il papà per Cristina
però insomma
la mamma ovviamente sottoscrive ma per
troppo amore l'hanno fatto perché mi
volevano proteggere da un mondo che
allora era ancora più difficile per le
donne e quindi scelgo lingue che era
un'altra delle mie passioni perché io ho
ancora come vi ho spiegato Non sapevo
quale fosse cioè lo sapevo ma non ero
certa E quindi cosa faccio mi iscrivo a
lingue e vabbè finiscono l'università Ma
ve la faccio breve studio lavoro perché
iniziano l'università inizia anche a
lavorare e studiare prendo una laurea
poi mi iscrivo faccio due Master E
prendo anche una seconda laurea Mi sono
laureata l'anno scorso Ma non sono qui a
farvi l'elenco a farmi il mio curriculum
per carità assolutamente non lo voglio
fare però questo per dirvi che dal 1991
Cioè da quando ho finito la scuola a
quando ho iniziato poi ho fatto
l'università che ho finito in questo In
questo frangente diciamo dal 1991 al
Io sono cresciuta sono diventata una
donna
mi aveva avviato un percorso di carriera
avevo fatto tutti quegli step che fanno
tutti ed era arrivata un buon livello
ero contenta ero contenta Avevo anche
provato come potete vedere la lasaida
avevo provato anche a costruire una
famiglia le passioni le vedete perché
c'è una macchina ci sono le moto quindi
insomma c'era tutto ero una persona
diciamo arrivata comunque avevo
avevo preso questo percorso e stavo
cercando di portarlo avanti però in
questo appunto tra il 1991 e il 2014
accade una cosa nel 2008 proprio
all'apice avevo 36 anni e
non riesco più a camminare un giorno
faccio fatica a camminare comincia
incespicare i dolori aumentano perdo
completamente la sensibilità dalla vita
in giù e niente Vado a farmi vedere
ovviamente diagnosi sclerosi multipla
una volta in testa Credetemi una volta
in testa una volta in testa e avevo due
scelte o sedermi sul divano come mi
avevano anche indicato perché allora la
letteratura medica suggeriva di stare
tranquilli cercare di non di non
sforzarsi più di tanto oppure provare a
fare qualcosa di diverso ero con la mia
mamma che purtroppo non c'è più ero con
la mia mamma e la mia mamma ha detto
Cristina Devi avere fiducia il Diavolo
non è mai brutto come si pittura vedrai
in qualche modo ce la faremo hai avuto
ragione io sono andata avanti ho seguito
quella che era la mia passione Voi
direte Ma la passione per i motori No
perché la passione per me quella quella
dei motori ce l'avevo ancora sicuramente
perché la carica di garzone non me l'ha
mai tolta nessuno ce l'ho ancora adesso
E vi assicuro che col papà ce l'ho
ancora adesso
però era un'altra cosa che mi teneva in
piedi era la passione per la vita perché
avevo tante passioni Ed ora con gli
animali e drovo i cani adoravo la
montagna qualsiasi cosa che Mi riempiva
il cuore e Quindi quello che mi ha
tenuto in piedi quindi ho agito diciamo
come poteva essere agire in azienda
Questo è il problema Quali sono i miei
strumenti sicuramente li imponderabile
io non potevo non potevo controllarlo
Però avevo degli strumenti potevo
studiare potevo informarmi potevo andare
ai convegni e capire che cosa potevo
fare per combattere un nemico invisibile
perché Credetemi la disabilità
invisibile è una cosa che è ancora non
voglio togliere assolutamente non vuole
essere irriverente verso Chi ha
patologie differenti ma
è molto difficile perché quando una
persona di fronte a te non beve quello
che hai non ti crede quindi devi
combattere due volte devi combattere una
prima volta contro te stesso e anche far
capire agli altri che
in realtà hai un problema anche che tu
non vuoi ammettere perché combatti con
te stesso
perché vuoi dimostrare a te stesso che
sei ancora quello di prima che non è
successo niente anzi sei anche meglio E
qui la passione ti aiuta perché se tu
hai la passione per la vita dici Ok Cosa
devo fare e ho ricominciato Quindi cosa
succede
nel 2014 accadono altre cose come vi ho
detto 2008 2014 ci sono altre cose perdo
il lavoro per due volte il lavoro la
famiglia purtroppo non
quella che avevo cercato di costruire
non è andata bene Quindi avevo bisogno
di qualche cosa d'altro avevo bisogno di
attaccarmi a qualcosa avevo bisogno di
trovare la mia passione mi aiutasse a
fare qualcos'altro Io ho iniziato a
correre Ho iniziato a correre Ho trovato
delle persone perché il condividere è
fondamentale per la passione ho iniziato
a correre ho tratto dei gruppi a Milano
comincia a correre
un chilometro tira l'altro diventano 5
diventano 10 diventano le maratone ve la
faccio breve comincia a correre 2016 nel
2016-2017 la prima maratona nel 2019
2017/19 ne fate 9 mi sono stufata perché
sono non è che può continuare a correre
Forest camper a uno io non volevo
emularlo assolutamente vado a vedere una
gara di Triathlon nel 2018 e amore a
prima vista e dico Caspita io l'anno
prossimo voglio essere qui perché vi
dico questo perché quando prima vi ho
dato la definizione
il discorso di disciplina determinazione
senza un'etichetta su calendario la
passione conta Ma devi avere un
obiettivo io mi sono messa mie etichetta
sul calendario nel 2019 ero in griglia
di partenza per il primo Sprint e così
ho fatto poi c'è stato il covid una
serie di cose ve la faccio breve perché
non voglio tenervi nel 2021 faccio il
primo Olimpico c'è il primo riepilo
Caspita va bene Chiamo l'allenatore gli
dico senti cosa ne pensi se io facessi
anche un medio
Sì Cristina Puoi farlo è stessa cosa è
andata avanti a maggio 2022 secondo
medio perché vi dico questo perché a
luglio del 2022 ho fatto l'Iron Man cosa
ha voluto cosa ha significato l'Iron Man
Adesso vi spiego faccio un passo
indietro io fino a tre anni fa non
dicevo nulla di quello che di quello che
mi era accaduto perché non volevo che le
persone mi guardassero in maniera
diversa e perché volevo assolutamente
dimostrare a me stessa che questa cosa
non mi aveva buttato giù i dolori sono
tanti perché la sclerosi multipla è una
malattia
neurodegenerativa progressiva quindi io
non so come sarò domani e quindi volevo
assolutamente fare di tutto e di più
e quindi ho detto ok anche l'Iron Man ma
non era perché l'Iron Man perché tutti
devono fare un Iron Man ma semplicemente
perché l'Iron Man mi ha dato quella
consapevolezza
di avere ancora un valore e di poter
passare un po' di speranza a qualcuno
perché ognuno può avere proprio Iron Man
possono essere 100 metri possono essere
200 qualsiasi cosa però il fatto di di
poter arrivare in fondo ti dà una
sicurezza ti dà una consapevolezza dice
ci sono ancora lo posso fare e questo
senza passione non si può fare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
in questo
l'arrivo alla Iron Man ha avuto un
qualche tappa In più ha avuto qualche
tappa in più una in particolare Ho
conosciuto una persona che si chiama
Alex Zanardi faccio parte della sua
squadra si chiama obiettivo 3 è formata
da ragazzi fantastici perché il
movimento paralimpico è fantastico e
tanto che vi faccio vedere qualche foto
delle mie delle mie passioni il
movimento paralimpico mi ha insegnato
tantissimo Mi ha insegnato
a avere il coraggio di chiedere di
chiedere aiuto perché non è un segno di
forza è un segno di debolezza ma anzi di
forza mi ha insegnato la pazienza Mi ha
insegnato
a capire che
quello che vogliamo non arriva quando lo
vogliamo noi arriva solo quando è il
momento quindi la pazienza è
fondamentale e Eccolo qua
come vedete Ho messo anche delle foto un
po' Matte perché ho dei carissimi amici
che sono anche in sala oggi che mi
supportano perché senza la passione
c'è la passione non condivisa credo che
non possa portare Cioè può portare però
credo che condividerla sia la cosa che
sia la cosa più bella al mondo questi
qui mentre Sto affogando perché io non
vi ho detto una cosa quando mi sono
iscritta all'airon Man Io ho iniziato a
notare due anni fa quindi in realtà
quando ho fatto il primo Sprint ho
iniziato a notare sei mesi prima io ho
iniziato a nuotare a 48 anni quindi
questo per dirvi qui Questa è la prova
che stavo quasi affogando quindi si può
fare la passione riesce a farvi fare
queste cose io non volevo dimostrare
nulla nessuno Volevo solo dimostrare le
cose a me stessa perché ripeto fino a
tre anni tre anni fa tre anni e mezzo fa
non lo sapeva nessuno non volevo dirlo
non volevo dirlo perché forse devo fare
pace ancora con me dovevo dimostrare
ancora qualcosa a me stessa e poi un mio
manager in azienda
aveva visto un articolo l'ha pubblicato
e mi ha fatto un regalo mi ha fatto un
regalo perché io ero con me in una
matriosca me ne sono accorta e sto
accorgendo adesso ogni anno tolgo uno
strato e viene fuori la Cristina che
nemmeno io conoscevo ma nemmeno la
Cristina sapeva quale fosse la sua vera
passione non lo sapeva seguiva degli
istinti come anche altri speaker hanno
detto e pian pianino è arrivata questo e
l'airon l'ha fatto perché
ripeto questo manager mi ha fatto questo
regalo liberandomi da questa gabbia una
sorta di gabbia una sorta di come un
guscio dell'uovo che ti protegge ma è
anche morbido per poter uscire non sei
dentro e vuoi uscire e io ho fatto così
questo manager mi ha fatto veramente
questo regalo mi ha fatto uscire perché
io dicevo continuavo a dire a me stessa
non è possibile che la mia paura mi
blocchi e non mi faccia aiutare le
persone io voglio aiutare le persone
quindi ho scoperto pian piano che la mia
passione per la vita e per lo sport che
mi ha aiutato tantissimo mi ha aiutato
era ancora più disciplina essere
organizzata capire dove volevo arrivare
e questo ne benefici anche la parte
della parte professionale sicuramente
mi ha mi ha liberato veramente questa
cosa mi ha Io ringrazio anche quello che
mi è accaduto perché non queste cose le
cose che accadono nella vita a volte
sono non sono di facile digestione anzi
quasi mai si capisce solo dopo
guardandosi indietro si capisce come
diceva come diceva Steve Jobs che sono
i puntini verranno Uniti da delle linee
non sappiamo ancora quali disegni uscirà
però uscirà qualcosa e lo capirete solo
dopo questi sono il mio papà e la mia
mamma la mia mamma non c'è più
però
la mia mamma mi diceva Cristina sei una
signora quando ti alzi dal letto quindi
ricordatevelo che è fuori di dire domani
domani non ce n'è più quindi Tagga con
fantasmi diceva in milanese no e
tachidee FIDAS perché la vita sa di cosa
hai bisogno Infatti io vi ho Vi ho messo
qui qualche frase e nulla Volevo
semplicemente condividervi questa
abbiate fiducia nella vita perché è nero
a volte è nero non si riesce a digerire
non si capisce ma c'è sempre un senso
noi non lo capiamo subito ma il senso
cioè il senso Cioè io non sarei la
Cristina che sono adesso se non mi fosse
capitato quello che mi è capitato e non
dico grazie alla malattia però
anche anche quello perché nessuno fa
piacere ho messo una frase di Alex che a
me piace tantissimo che è proprio
Scusate metto gli occhiali perché sono
concentrata credo appunto che la
curiosità sia l'unica cosa che abbiamo
bisogno nella vita se sei curioso
troverai la tua passione i risultati che
avrai saranno il risultato di quanta
passione metterai nella tua vita perché
lui ha dato un nome alla fatica al fatto
di uscire con la pioggia col vento ha
dato un nome ha dato un nome veramente
l'ha dato alla passione e io volevo
ringraziare davvero
tutti voi che siete qui oggi e anche chi
hanno Chi ha fatto parte del di questo
viaggio meraviglioso e che chi ne farà
parte è una cosa che volevo dirti che
qui Voi vedete tre persone io non so
cosa vediate voi Io vedo solo tre atleti
sono tre atleti che hanno strumenti
diversi perché un ragazzo è in
carrozzina e
rubo ancora un secondo questo ragazzo si
chiama Ivan a un Luis tetraplegico
perché per salvare due persone in mare è
rimasto così non riusciva a muoversi
quando è tornato su dall'acqua ha fatto
il mezzo Iron Man come qualche mese fa
il ragazzo in mezzo non ha l'uso delle
braccia però corre lo stesso è nuota
senza braccia e poi vabbè c'è la
sottoscritta che va bene Insomma fa
finta di fare l'atleta Quindi io qui
vedo solo tre atleti che dà la passione
se sono mossi dalla passione e
cercano di raggiungerla e di di
riempirsi di questa passione con i loro
strumenti come te sono strumenti
differenti ma L'obiettivo è lo stesso
vanno nella stessa direzione
[Applauso]